>> LIBERAL HACKS CAN'T QUIT
THEIR ATTACKS.
THE HATREDS VIEWERS STILL CAN'T
FIND VIEWERS.
DON LEMON TOLD HIS 10 REMAINING
VIEWERS THAT REPUBLICANS ARE
DOING SOMETHING THAT IS VERY
DANGEROUS TO SOCIETY.
NOW, 2 MILLION VIEWERS ARE GOING
TO SEE IT.
>> REPUBLICANS ARE DOING
SOMETHING VERY DANGEROUS TO OUR
SOCIETY, AND WE HAVE TO
ACKNOWLEDGE IT AS AMERICANS AND
WE DON'T WE ARE NOT DOING OUR
JOB.
AND IT'S LIKE, THEY HAVE A LOT
TO ANSWER FOR IN THIS MOMENT.
>> SO MUCH FOR BEING LESS
PARTISAN.
PUSHING A MOVE TO THE MIDDLE,
THE MIDDLE LASTED AS LONG AS
BRIAN SELTZER CHUGGING DOWN CORN
SYRUP LIKE WATER.
MSNBC INTELLIGENCE ANALYSIS THIS
WEEK RAMBLED ON ABOUT THE
HEARING AND THE RIGHT WING
EXTREMISM, IMPLYING THAT THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY HAS BECOME AN
INSURGENCY.
>> A YEAR AND A HALF AGO, PEOPLE
WERE ACTUALLY SAYING THAT IT'S
CRAZY, AND IT IS.
IT IS WELL ON ITS WAY.
YOU KNOW, WHERE NOW THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY MAY HAVE TO
FIGHT.
SHOWING THAT AMERICANS ARE YOUR
NEIGHBORS.
>> HE IS OGLING SUGGESTING THIS
BECAUSE THEY WANT TO KILL YOU,
BUT IF REPUBLICAN SAID THAT THEY
WOULD BE CHASTISED FOR
INCITEMENT OR THEY WOULD BE LIZ
CHENEY.
A TERRORIST ORGANIZATION IN THE
LAST DECADES IN ANOTHER COUNTRY,
AND LASTLY, THIS GUY IS CALLED
AN INTELLIGENCE ANALYST?
IT WOULD BE LIKE A FEUD WITH
JERRY NADLER.
>> WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF THIS?
>> WELL, I HAVE A LOT TO SAY
ABOUT THIS.
FIRST I WISH THAT THEY WOULD
COME OUT AND ACKNOWLEDGE THAT HE
IS NOT FOR DEMOCRACY, HE DOESN'T
THINK PEOPLE HAVE THE RIGHT TO A
DIFFERENT OPINION AND HE'S NOT
AN OBJECTIVE JOURNALIST.
TEN YEARS AGO, MAYBE LESS, IF
THE CNN ANCHOR CAME OUT WITH
THIS AMOUNT OF DISDAIN FOR HALF
OF THE AMERICAN POPULATION, AND
WHATEVER THE LEFT ACCUSES THE
RIGHT OF DOING, THEY THEMSELVES
ARE GUILTY OF.
RECALL KAMALA HARRIS
FUNDRAISING.
AND YOU REMEMBER WHEN CHUCK
SCHUMER SPOKE ABOUT WHEN BRETT
CAVANAUGH HAS TO PAY THE PRICE,
AND NOW YOU HAVE THE SKY WHO
WROTE A BOOK ARGUING THAT THE
WAY TO COUNTER ISIS IS TO
EMPOWER SYRIA.
HE ALSO SAID 113 TERRORIST MEN
113 TERRORISTFIGHTERS, SERVICEMN
WERE KILLED, I'M NOT TAKING
ADVICE FROM THE SKY.
THE GREATEST THREAT TO OUR
DEMOCRACY IS THOSE THAT DO NOT
BELIEVE IN FREE AND FAIR
ELECTIONS, THAT DON'T BELIEVE IN
FREE SPEECH.
THE LEFT PRESENTS THE THREAT AND
THEY ARE OPEN AND HONEST, AND IT
IS VERY SCARY.
♪ ♪
[CHEERS]
[APPLAUSE]
>> LET'S GO BACK TO DON LEMON.
DO YOU THINK THAT HE KNOWS THAT
HIS DAYS ARE NUMBERED?
LIKE IT IS IN OPEN CONFLICT,
WITH WHAT THEY ARE GOING TO DO
AND THEN HE SAID THAT HALF THE
COUNTRY IS A BUNCH OF CRIMINALS
THAT JOURNALISTS SHOULD NOT TAKE
SERIOUSLY?
>> EITHER THAT OR HE GOT SUPER
DRUNK THE NIGHT BEFORE BECAUSE
HE SAID THAT A MILLION TIMES
BEFORE.
IT SHOULD BE SOMETHING LIKE HEY,
THAT'S CRAZY TO SAY, BUT IT'S
NOT, BECAUSE IT'S CRAZY HOW MANY
TIMES HE KEEPS SAYING IT.
AND IT ALSO DOES NOT HELP
ANYBODY.
BECAUSE THE WAY THAT PEOPLE DO
BECOME RADICALIZED WHEN THEY DO
IS NOBODY ELSE TALKING TO THEM
WHEN THEY GO DEEPER AND DEEPER
AND THEY GO EVEN DEEPER INTO
THAT, HE SEES HIMSELF AS A HERO
FOR SAYING THESE THINGS, BUT
HE'S NOT SOLVING ANYTHING AND
COULD BE MAKING THINGS WORSE.
TO THINK THAT YOUR AVERAGE
PERSON THAT MAY BE VOTED FOR
DONALD TRUMP IS A MONSTER, IT'S
NOT IN LINE WITH REALITY AND
THAT'S WHAT MAKES IT
IRRESPONSIBLE.
>> YOU KNOW NEIGHBORS FIGHTING
NEIGHBORS.
>> IT WOULD BE FUN.
>> AND THEN YOU JUST HEAR HIM
SCREAM.
>> A COUPLE OF THINGS.
BROTHER NANCE, THEY FIRST SAID
THIS AND SET I WAS CRAZY.
MY BROTHER WAS SAYING THAT AS
WELL.
[LAUGHTER]
BUT I THINK THAT YOU ARE VERY
RIGHT, AND WE HAVE BOTH BEEN
FIRED A TIMER TO, WE HAVE THIS
PHRASE CALLED GOING OUT IN A
BLAZE OF GLORY.
HE KNOWS HIS DAYS ARE NUMBERED,
NOW HE'S TRYING TO DO WHAT HE
DOES.
BECAUSE HE IS THE OFFICIAL
SPOKESPERSON FOR THE WOKE.
AND HE'S LIKE HEY, HE'S ALONE ON
THE ISLAND.
HE DIDN'T REALIZE EVER SINCE
PEOPLE STARTED WARNING FOR
THINGS, YOU KNOW, THIS IS HIS
BLAZE OF GLORY.
HE IS NOT PLAYING AROUND, HE IS
ON THE LOSING SIDE AND HE IS
DARING HIM TO DO IT.
AND I WOULD NOT DOUBLE DARE
THEM.
>> I HAVE ONLY ONE COMMENT THAT
IF MALCOLM NANCE AND DON LEMON
ARE GOING TO BE THE ENEMY
GENERALS, THIS IS GOING TO BE
THE SHORTEST CIVIL WAR OF ALL
TIME.
♪ ♪
♪ AND I MEAN, WHAT ARE WE GOING
TO NAME THE BATTLE?
VENOMOUS CHARGE?
>> COMING U